you may have noticed that that little
one badge has reappeared above the
Settings icon on your iPhone that means
iOS 9 is ready for you to download you
probably know the basics of what's
coming there's a new font called San
Francisco there's a new proactive menu
which shows all the contacts apps and
headlines Apple things you want to see
right now there's the new news app big
updates to the podcasts and notes app
carplay and home kit transit directions
in map and that funky new multitasking
thing on the iPad you know that the
keyboard finally shows whether you're
typing in all caps or not it's all good
stuff but there's also a lot in iOS 9
that's not quite so obvious but that you
should still pay attention to because
it'll make your life a whole lot easier
the first thing is Siri you've probably
tried Syria before and it was probably
terrible you should try it again now
series great for searching the web
controlling your home and your car and
generally doing all kinds of tasks
across your iPhone Siri show me pictures
from Lake Tahoe search in general is a
big deal on iOS 9 over the left of your
home screen there's that proactive
window it has a big search box at the
top which lets you search for apps
contacts even things on the web the
whole idea of iOS 9 is that you spend
less time figuring out which app to use
and more time just doing second search
is a big part one small thing that
you'll use a lot is the new battery menu
in settings which shows in detail which
apps are killing your battery there's
also a really useful low-power mode
which you can flip on to make the phone
last longer in a pinch trust me you will
use this feature here's one you might
miss but shouldn't if you get a
notification and tap on it you'll be
taken to that app as always but now
there's a little button in the top left
corner if you tap on that you'll go
right back to where you were before you
got the notification it's crazy handy
there are lots of new features like this
lots of them there are even three new
apps which you probably won't use much
so add them to the list of crap you'll
never use and should just dump into a
folder you never open here's mine in
addition to all that iOS 9 also seems to
improve both performance and battery
life and for those two reasons alone the
upper it's worth doing and then once you
get into Siri and search and all the
cool things proactive can do
be even better and if and when you buy
an iPhone 6s or an iPad pro you'll
really start to see what iOS 9 which
iphone should I buy